I never like to use numbers right saying
oh I only work with clients who have
obtained you know a 250 000 uh portfolio
right but it does benefit them to to
have that much to to make sure that
we're giving them all that they can get
um because what we do if we have a very
uh systematic process right so if they
only come in with a smaller amount we're
not able to do these things that we're
specializing in welcome to 20 minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome and hello to another episode of
20-minute leaders today I'm with Ryan
Larson a seasoned wealth advisor and the
founder and CEO of First Line Financial
LLC based in Scottsdale Arizona Ryan
embodies the qualities of a trustworthy
leader and believes everyone deserves a
chance to lead a life they can be proud
of as they enter retirement he credits
his empathetic leadership approach to
his experience as a firefighter a career
that gave him a sense of purpose and a
lifelong passion to helping others
mitigate risk in his new business Memoir
ladder to leader my journey from failure
to fire to Financial Freedom Ryan shares
the true story of his Evolution from a
troubled youth to a successful founder
and CEO and the many life and business
lessons he learned along the way he
recounts the struggles he experienced in
school how he felt like an outsider at
home and the unexpected turns his life
took including some of the lowest points
that eventually led him to where he is
today it was Ryan's mom who first
encouraged him to join the Fire
Department Explorer Program where the
entrance exam transformed his mindset
and gave him the confidence that would
carry him through challenges he has yet
to face later he discovered his passion
for investing in financial education
becoming an expert in helping people
protect their life savings from
unnecessary risks and Market
fluctuations by creating tax
efficiencies in his practice at first
line Financial he focuses on supporting
retirees and transitioning Boomers with
all of their wealth management needs
whether helping them grow assets for the
future or preserving and reallocating
them in retirement he utilizes the
unique combination of time-tested
strategies for both Securities and
insurance offerings
foreign
Larson welcome to 28 minute leaders
thank you so much for being here Ryan
Michael it's a pleasure thank you for
having me all the way from Arizona right
yes yeah hot sunny Arizona uh it's
interesting because it's starting to
cool down right now so the weather's
getting nice and there's a lot of people
outside enjoying themselves and you're
here stuck with me in this virtual
podcast so I'm hopefully I'll make it
fun over these 20 minutes uh Ryan um you
know your
your journey you know on one hand speaks
for itself on the other hand it's so so
incredible and and it sounds like it was
quite quite an adventure uh which is
very non-trivial I'm excited to connect
the dots with you and um leave these 20
minutes with a new understanding of
different possibilities and and at least
from from your own perspective
including some thoughts from from your
business Memoir a ladder to leader my
journey from failure to fire which we'll
talk about to Financial Freedom and so
Ryan
um you know share with me a little bit
about you know your upbringing and and
I'd love to sort of walk through your
journey and uncover bits and pieces that
you're taking with you as you are now
and doing some some pretty amazing
things with with Finance so go ahead
yeah it's been a it's been an
interesting ride it hasn't been easy for
sure
um you know I was uh I was a little bit
of a troubled kid uh growing up I got in
a lot of trouble
um I was a uh I was a good fighter uh
actually
um I was kind of known as being a a good
fighter and um I didn't really like that
to tell you the truth
um I ran with the wrong you know crowd
in high school and just uh needed to
really find myself and After High School
graduating didn't really know what I
wanted to do with my life uh once again
hanging with the wrong crowd it just
wasn't taking me anywhere that I knew in
my heart I wanted to go
um I really had to do a lot of you know
uh soul searching and find my true
selves who I really am not trying to fit
the mold of you know that High School uh
mentality growing up of trying to always
fit in
and I've I found that once you kind of
start to break uh you know that mold and
just try to find who you truly are what
you truly are passionate about what
you're good at what you're not good at
what what your you know quirks and
um you know just the just to be uh light
with yourself just to give yourself a
sense of um
uh reassurance that everything is going
to be okay no matter what direction you
take and so I think that's where coming
out of high school I needed to do that
and
my mom actually helped me with that a
lot
um there was also some time yeah my my
mom she was she's an incredible woman
she's had cancer for the last 17 years
they actually wow
five years to live and it's been 17
years now so she just like myself she's
a fighter all the way through
and I came home one day from work and I
was just kind of bouncing from job to
job
not happy
I came home one one afternoon and she
had
um an opportunity
which was uh to be introduced to the
fire Explorer Program which is
essentially you go and learn about the
fire service
and what it takes to be a fireman uh you
know what's the process like to get
hired
and she presented this with uh to me and
I was really taken back
I was a high school wrestler
I was really good at team sports and I
knew that
the fire department is really uh about a
team environment as well and so that's
really what extra that's really what
drew me to start that endeavor when I
was around 21 years of age
wow tell me a little bit about that
experience and how how that changed you
I had to grow up fast to actually it was
uh it was interesting because the the
very first night that I went down to
this training academy and it my eyes lit
up and it was it was such a cool sight
to see there was fire trucks down there
doing some training
um they were like pulling hoes off the
trucks and ladders and it just liked it
looked like this beautiful uh you know
Orchestra if you will everyone kind of
knew what was going on and it they knew
it seemed like they had purpose of what
they were doing and then they were
enjoying themselves that was the biggest
takeaway for me they looked like they
were having fun they were physically fit
and that's really kind of what's up my
alley is just
being passionate about what I'm doing in
my life
staying you know physically fit through
you know through these years and now
having two kids that's a really uh focal
point in my life so it's just it drew me
to uh you know the fire department
really
that was my calling right out of high
school and I knew it the day that I
stepped foot on that Trading Academy
well and so some some of those you know
personal maturity and Leadership traits
that you gained I I'd love to to dig
into those a little bit and how perhaps
they are now reflected in in the person
that you are today and the success that
you have in the business that you run
yeah definitely with the fire department
um you really do have to be a good
leader
you know I wanted to make sure I kind of
align myself with a good Mentor who was
very reputable
um had a good reputation uh on and off
the job and I kind of just flew under
his wings
and looked at him as what I wanted to be
one day and it was it was a really he
was his name was Mark he was he was a
great Captain he's actually passed away
now
um he got cancer and unfortunately he
passed away about three years ago I
think the anniversary was just a few
weeks ago
but he also
was a good Hunter and
hunting was another passion of mine
so he introduced me to a gentleman his
name was Dwayne Adams and he was a big
Outfitter and
um as soon as you know I met Mark and
Dwayne I started getting
the sense of like what those
characteristics
will will look like and people that are
respected and those people that are
respected you know in the
you know in the world are you know
they're good listeners first off
right they they respect everyone
they don't try to judge too quickly they
want to get to know you and who you are
as a person
um and those are some of the things that
I really learn very quickly and to be a
good leader you need to be a good
follower and then you can lead by
following eventually so with that being
said I found myself taking those
characteristics you know and essentially
using those skill sets that I learned
early and applied them often in my
career as a firefighter and I think that
is essentially what gave me the platform
to continue to you know expand my
Horizon per se
all right so let's let's jump to to
where you are today the business that
you founded with with your wife which I
also have to understand a little bit how
what that's like and talk to me a little
bit about what you do today and then
we'll connect it back to to use a
firefighter
yeah yeah so it's it's a it was a very
interesting switch so for the listeners
um I actually own my own Financial firm
and you know if we could kind of like
back backtrack a little bit I was never
good in school right and here I am today
owning you know my own Financial firm
with a really good client base
who are
you know it's kind of like my tribe you
know they're they they have not left me
and you know uh since the beginning and
it just it just showcases that I'm
trying to do things the right way in the
financial space
so obviously with being in the financial
world I know
you know how people sometimes summarize
financial advisors or Wall Street and
you know uh those Brokers that they work
with sometimes and I'm almost trying to
collect cut that mold just break that
that mold whereas you don't need to work
with you know those types of guys who
are just trying to like sell you stuff
here you could actually work with
someone who is just like you very
personable has those good
characteristics being a good listener
um understanding your situation and then
applying what you know what my skill
sets are now to their situation to
eventually hopefully
um you know set them up financially
better than they are right now
and what and what does that process look
like from when a person approaches how
does that engagement absolutely go
through
yeah so that's actually your that's kind
of a secret sauce with with my firm is I
work with three different firms in the
valley and what I found Michael is that
there wasn't really anything special
there
um you know it was essentially
kind of cookie cutter if you will so
when I kind of started jumping from firm
to firm trying to find that that
connection right that I can resonate
with and I could build a good base and I
could introduce those clients to that
firm and then stand by that firm
throughout the years I just I wasn't
finding what I was looking for
and it was my wife you know when I came
home one night is you know I talked to
her and I said gosh I'm just not finding
what I want in this financial field and
she said well Ryan you know you have a
lot of um you know people that respect
you in this industry in the financial
industry you know why don't you start
your own firm and I was I was
taken by that because I knew I could do
it but when you have your wives to say
Hey you know go for it it just gives you
that kind of like that thrust like okay
you know she she has my back on this and
uh that's where it kind of started you
know I started studying for you know uh
these different tests and and
essentially started my own Ria it's it's
called a registered investment advisory
firm and I started my own process and I
trademarked that process it's called The
Wrap process the written retirement
action plan and it allows clients to
work through a process
and understand
exactly what's happening
at each stage in the process and then I
kind of uh I make it very simple Michael
like Financial you know the financial
lingo out there is very complicated
sometimes and what would you do is
especially like if we build if you're
going to build a house right it's gonna
you know you're gonna go through this
process and sometimes you might work
with a an architect and you might change
walls and roofs you know pitches and
windows and that's essentially what
we're doing with each of our clients
we're we're customizing their experience
and we're building them that custom
house that they're looking for and
essentially that's going to allow them
to feel more comfortable every time they
you know walk in the doors like hey
everything's gonna be fine I'm in my you
know in my uh safe space and I know how
everything is working
how much of that is
strategic thinking around wealth
management or retirement planning versus
understanding the different options and
and simplifying this complexity that's
been created around the space so you
know or or maybe a combination of both
yeah it's it's
somewhat technical right I mean
obviously you have to use different
investment vehicles to kind of build
this you know custom home if you will
right so there's a lot of intricate
investment details that we will go
through with the client
but we won't get into those really hard
discussions now what do you even say
hard there was just in-depth discussions
about what those investment vehicles are
going to be doing until the third or
fourth visit it's really the first and
second visit where we're actually just
showing them at framework if you will
and then allowing them to digest that
framework
and once we have their buy-in
they get comfortable with me I get
comfortable with them I understand their
situation then we start to kind of move
you know the pieces of the puzzle down
the road a little bit and then once
everything is good that you know with
that we've met a couple times that's
where kind of that the devils are in the
details when it comes to the Investments
that we're using to really complete that
overall home that they're looking for
and how how similar are those strategies
if you take your random samples people
how similar would those strategies look
like versus really personalized and this
is you know not just fear from a general
question for people to consider as they
go about their their planning how how
much of it is sort of you know
there's a best practice that optimizes
for certain things or is it really
tailored to us to specific situations
I think every client that we work with
this is that is uh it is 100 custom
every time
because you know one strategy might not
work well with the next client and I'll
give you an example
um you might have a client with you know
let's call it a hundred or you know two
hundred thousand dollars
with that with that uh asset level
there's not a lot of opportunities that
you're gonna find besides like you know
stocks bonds and mutual funds kind of
like the old traditional investment
vehicles but as you kind of move up that
threshold once you get start you know
breaking these different thresholds
there's different things that come
available and
um I'll just use like a another quick
examples you know once you get to this
accredited investor you have a million
dollars
um of essentially liquid assets right
well you could start getting into more
uh um
I guess proprietary products right more
specialized vehicles
and that's just kind of where things
start to shift
um the conversation starts to shift a
little bit different and I get to kind
of start to pull a little bit more
arrows out of my quiver and educate the
client a little bit more about how fully
customized we are versus someone who
might only have once again 100 to 200
um we can't you know there's less uh
vehicles to kind of share with them
to be around you
and so what what was sort of the ideal
person to approach you is you had to
sort of locate the Persona that that
would be most relevant for working with
you
yeah so I think I I think our ideal
clients is you know I I never like to
use numbers right saying oh I only work
with clients who have obtained you know
a 250 000 uh portfolio right
but it does benefit them to to have that
much to to make sure that we're giving
them all that they can get
um because what we do if we have a very
uh systematic process right so if they
only come in with a smaller amount we're
not able to do these things that we're
specializing in which could be real
estate it could be private Equity it
could be Venture Capital
um it can be debt financing so there's
things that we definitely have uh you
know sought out
to educate us more than the next
financial firm out there and I think
that's just you know me wanting to be
the best advisor you know the best
fireman it's just it's just in my DNA to
make sure that I'm doing whatever I can
to optimize someone else's scenario
I love it and I love how you you just
connected it back to me uh to before and
uh writing sounds like quite a quite a
crazy journey and I look forward to
checking on the book as well and uh and
it sounds like you're very intentional
about you know the success of your
science and and thinking through you
know how what does it even mean to be
successful here and how do you create
success for for the different people
around you and so I really want to thank
you for taking the time to be here in
these 20 minutes I really enjoyed it and
I'm sure that it will continue making a
big positive impact on all those around
you so really thank you for taking the
time to be here and for sharing with me
your journey and your story and uh and I
look forward to keeping in touch so
thank you very much Ryan
thank you so much Michael it was a
pleasure